rund um das Thema himbeernchneiden
herrscht of so ein bisschen Verwirrung
weil es da zwei unterschiedliche
himbeergruppen gibt die man jeweils
unterschiedlich schneidet das sind die
Sommer und die herbsthimbeeren also
bevor ihr das himbeerschneiden Ganz sein
lasst und im nächsten Jahr nicht nur
weniger erntet sondern auch riskiert
dass ihr Pflanzenkrankheiten ins nächste
Jahr verschleppt zeige ich euch jetzt
alles was ihr beim himbeerschneiden
beachten müsst und am Ende gibt's sogar
einen Trick wenn ihr gar nicht so genau
wisst ob ihr Herbst oder sommerhimbeären
habt was ihr dann machen könnt um alles
richtig zu machen wir haben gerade
diesen Bauernhof hier gekauft und hatten
Glück denn es gibt schon himbeären auf
dem Hof das sind herbsthimbeären und an
denen zeige ich euch mal wie man die
schneidet der Unterschied zu den
sommerhimbeeren ist dass die
herbsthimbeären an den einjährigen
Trieben tragen das heißt wenn man sich
die mal anguckt dann sieht man dass an
jedem einzelnen trieb hier
fruchtrückstände zu sehen sind also man
sieht dass jeder einzelne trieb getragen
hat und teilweise hängen jetzt sogar
noch ein paar Bären dran egal ob ihr
Sommer oder Herbst den Bären habt ihr
schneidet die immer direkt nach der er
also jetzt im Herbst wo wir alle Früchte
abgeerntet haben ist die perfekte Zeit
um die herbsthimbeären zu schneiden und
weil die an den einjährigen Trieben
tragen können wir alle Triebe die wir
jetzt sehen einfach entfernen entweder
mit einem Messer oder mit einer
heckenschiere ist wichtig dass das Ganze
scharf ist und dass das Werkzeug sauber
ist weil man zwischen unterschiedlichen
Rosengewächsen auch Krankheiten
übertragen kann und bei meinen
herbstimbern schneide ich jetzt einfach
alle Triebe über den Boden ab das klingt
erstmal ziemlich radikal aber keine
Sorge die Pflanzen werden einfach im
nächsten Jahr wieder ne austreiben und
an diesen neuen Trieben dann ihre
Früchte tragen wenn ihr nur
herbsthimbeeren habt dann passt aber
noch mal ganz kurz auf es gibt nämlich
einen Trick weil wenn man herbsthinbeen
hat dann erntet man ja erst so im
September Oktober das heißt man muss
relativ lange auf seine Ernte warten
wenn Ihr schon ein bisschen früher im
Jahr ernten wollt dann könnt ihr
einzelne von diesen Trieben hier stehen
lassen nur ein paar und die nur so auf
die Hälfte zurückschneiden also ungefähr
hier weil die Triebe dann im nächsten
Jahr Seitentriebe bilden an denen sie
schon früher Früchte tragen werden das
bedeutet ihr habt dann eine kleinere
Ernte weil die zweijährigen Triebe sind
das dann ja nicht mehr so ertragreich
sind aber dafür werdet ihr dann an
diesen Trieben die ihr jetzt stehen
lasst nächstes Jahr früher ernten
[Musik]
können die sommerhimbeere dagegen trägt
logisch im Sommer aber nicht an den
einjährigen Trieben wie die
herbsthimbeere sondern an den zwe en
trieben die bildet also jedes Jahr
Triebe aus an denen im selben Jahr noch
keine Himbeeren wachsen we wenn wir bei
der alle Triebe absäbeln wie bei der
herbsthimbeere dann haben wir im
nächsten Jahr natürlich überhaupt keine
Ernte weil dann keine zweijährigen
Triebe mehr übrig sind aber auch eine
sommerhimbeere will geschnitten werden
und dann schaut ihr einfach wo sind an
eurer Pflanze diese fruchtreste und die
Triebe schneidet ihr ab alle die keine
Früchte getragen haben bleiben stehen
man kann bei sommerhimbeeren die ein und
zweijährigen Triebe auch an der Farbe
und unterscheiden die Triebe die schon
mal getragen haben also die zweijährigen
Triebe sind viel dunkler holziger und
Richtung Herbst also wenn man im Sommer
vergessen hat die zu schneiden sterben
die dann auch richtig ab also da sieht
man einen guten deutlichen Unterschied
egal ob ihr Sommer oder herbsthbeeren
habt beide freuen sich wenn sie nach dem
Schnitt eine Ladung Kompost
bekommen im Anschluss mulche ich meine
Himbeeren dann noch mit Laub s dass sie
gut geschützt in die Winterpause gehen
können aber vielleicht seid ihr euch ja
jetzt unsicher ob ihr Sommer oder
herbsthinbeären habt und dann gibt's
einen Trick mit dem ihr eure Pflanzen so
schneidet dass ihr trotzdem alles
richtig macht ihr guckt einfach jeden
einzelnen trieb an hatte der Früchte
wenn ja kommt der Weg überm Boden
abschneiden wenn nicht bleibt er stehen
so habt ihr nämlich falls ihr
sommerhimbeären habt die zweijährigen
Triebe erhalten damit die nächstes Jahr
tragen können und alle die schon
getragen haben wie z.B bei den
herbsthinbeären sind das alle sind schön
abgeschnitten s dass die Pflanze im
nächsten Jahr wieder richtig kräftig
austreiben kann aber himbeären sind ja
nicht die einzigen tollen Bären da
draußen ich habe letzte Woche ein ganz
ausführliches Video rund um das Thema
blaubeeranbau gemacht also schaut gerne
da drüben vorbei wenn euch das
interessiert und ihr Lust habt jetzt
noch Blaubeeren zu pflanzen jetzt ist
die perfekte Zeit dafür ansonsten geht
raus und macht die Welt ein bisschen
grüner und wir sehen uns im nächsten
Video wieder macht's gut
tschüss